les détonations se font entendre à des
kilomètres à la ronde signe de
l'intensité des combats sur le front les
soldats ont le visage marqué par la
fatigue mais tous refusent d'abandonner
leur poste
est importante parce qu'elle coupe les
routes et que c'est un terrain plus
élevé depuis sa hauteur tout est ouvert
pour les Russes Coffe donc c'est
important pour nous et pour eux
je pense que darkmouth résistera et même
si ce n'est pas le cas de nombreux
soldats Russie mourront je pense que
darkmouth les hantera dans leurs rêves
pendant plus d'un an ou d'une décennie
la ville est devenue le symbole de la
lutte entre les Russes et les Ukrainiens
pour le contrôle de la région du Dombas
pour keV la défense de barmoud constitue
déjà un succès stratégique par ailleurs
le président voulait dire Zelenski a
tenu à mettre fin aux rumeur d'un
retrait tactique rumeur qui se sont
répandu ces derniers jours
pendant ma réunion avec l'état-major
j'ai directement demandé au général
sirsky en charge de nos opérations et à
zalujni le chef d'état-major s'il
fallait se retirer ou renforcer nos
positions dans la ville tout de monde
dit de ne pas nous retirer et de
renforcer j'ai donc dit à l'état-major
de trouver les forces pour aider nos
gars à barmut
mais ces dernières semaines les rues
sont progressées au nord et au sud de la
ville coupant trois des quatre routes
d'approvisionnement des Ukrainiens
barmut revêt un caractère stratégique
limité mais qui est cherchent à épuiser
les forces et le moral de l'ennemi tout
en construisant de nouvelles lignes de
défense en parallèle